una de las propiedades más estupendas
que tiene el álgebra lineal es que
aparentemente puede representar a un
objeto matemático de un buen de formas
distintas y es justo lo que quiero ver
en este vídeo acerca del espacio nulo y
la independencia lineal pero recordemos
primero que era un espacio nulo si yo
tenía una matriz am y tenía un vector x
y esto era igual al vector 0 entonces el
espacio nulo de la matriz am es igual y
me estoy refiriendo al conjunto de
vectores x que existen en rn ojo aquí la
matriz a es una matriz de m por n y por
lo tanto el vector x para que la
multiplicación de una matriz por un
vector esté bien definida esto quiere
decir que el vector x tiene que tener en
entradas el vector x existe en rn y por
cierto habíamos dicho que si el vector x
existen de rn entonces el vector 0 como
berto resultante es un vector de m
entradas el espacio en uno es el
conjunto de todos los vectores x que
estén de rn
tales que cumplen la propiedad de que la
matriz a multiplicada por el vector x es
igual al vector 0 que como habíamos
dicho el vector 0 es de entradas o el
vector 0 existe en rn y bueno es de esta
manera que definimos al espacio nulo así
que es hora de trabajar bastante con
ideas que tengan que ver con este
espacio nulo y lo primero que quiero que
veas y lo que habíamos dicho alguna vez
es que la matriz a la podemos convertir
en una matriz de vectores columna es
decir este es un vector columna este es
otro electro columna y tenemos n
columnas por lo tanto tenemos n vectores
columnas entonces hablando de esta
manera podemos decir que si yo separó a
esta matriz a en cada uno de sus
vectores columna entonces la matriz a la
podemos ver de la siguiente manera la
podemos ver como el vector 1 columna el
vector 2 columnas y hasta el vector n
columna y bueno si a esta matriz a la
multiplicó por el vector x que es lo que
quiero para tener mi espacio nulo
entonces déjame poner aquí a mi vector x
x 1 x 2
esta x n ya tengo aquí a mi vector x y
yo agarro y tomo esta multiplicación que
me va a quedar pues por definición y
esto es justo lo que habíamos visto en
el primer vídeo en el que multiplicamos
una matriz con un vector esto lo
podríamos escribir de la siguiente
manera como x 1 que multiplica el vector
1 + x2 que multiplica el vector 2 + así
hasta llegar a x n que multiplica el
vector n + puntitos más x n que
multiplica al vector n y justo así
habíamos visto que era otra forma de
escribir la multiplicación de una matriz
por un vector es decir esto es justo
una combinación lineal de los vectores
columna de la matriz am y bueno si
quiero que esto un plan ecuación lineal
homogénea es decir que sea igual al
vector cero entonces esto me va a
implicar que todo esto que tengo escrito
aquí arriba tenga que ser igual al
vector cero es decir x como lo acabamos
de construir esto es igual a cero que
por cierto date cuenta que esta es una
combinación lineal de los vectores
columnas de la matriz y esto tiene que
ser igual al vector 0 y en este momento
cuando debo de hacer estragos en tu
mente y algo debe de estar sonando
mágicamente en tu cabeza porque justo
esto es una forma de ver dependencia e
independencia lineal si nosotros tomamos
estos vectores que es una combinación
lineal de vectores y vemos que las
constantes son todas iguales a cero
entonces los vectores son linealmente
independientes y si todas las constantes
x 1 x 2 hasta x n alguna es distinta de
0 entonces hablamos de dependencia
lineal y es justo lo que vimos en el
vídeo sobre independencia y dependencia
lineal así que déjenme escribirlo b1 b2
así hasta vende todos los vectores
columna de la matriz am son linealmente
independientes linealmente
independientes sin todas las constantes
x1 x2 así esta x n son todas 0 o dicho
de otra manera el vector x es el vector
0 déjame ponerlo aquí tenemos una
combinación lineal de vectores y estos
vectores son linealmente
dependientes si cumplen que x1 y x2 x 3
así todas las constantes x son iguales a
0 todas y esto es un sí solo si si se
cumple que todas las constantes x son
iguales a cero entonces hablamos de
vectores linealmente independientes y si
hablamos de vectores linealmente
independientes se tiene que cumplir que
el vector x sea el vector 0 es la única
manera de que nos de que sean
linealmente independientes es decir
buscamos que x 1 que x 2 que así hasta x
n sean igual a 0 para hablar de
independencia lineal o el soldado caso
estamos hablando de que si los vectores
b1 b2 b así hasta bnc linealmente
independientes entonces todas las x
tienen que ser igual a 0 y por lo tanto
mi vector x tendría que ser ni vector 0
el vector x tendrá que ser el vector 0
porque todas sus componentes todas las x
son iguales a 0 en dado caso de que
hablemos de linealmente independiente y
bueno como dijimos que es un sí sólos y
entonces déjenme poner también el
regreso qué quiere decir esto que si
nosotros tenemos que ver 1 b 2
3b hasta vende todos los vectores
columna de la matriz a son linealmente
independientes entonces la única
solución de la ecuación lineal homogénea
asociada es decir a x igual a 0 a x
igual a cero su única solución es que el
vector x sea el vector cero y esto es
muy importante la única solución es que
el vector x se iguala al vector cero y
bueno si el vector 0 es la única
solución a esta ecuación línea la
homogénea asociada entonces estoy
diciendo que el espacio nulo de la
matriz am es igual al vector cero porque
el único vector que cumple esta ecuación
es decir mi vector x pues mi única
solución es el vector nudo x igual a
cero y ojo no pierdas nunca en cuenta
que estamos hablando de vectores
linealmente independientes solamente en
el caso de que tenemos vectores
linealmente independientes esto es muy
importante pero aquí estoy diciendo algo
también muy importante porque no olvido
ha pasado llegamos a una igualdad que
era bastante útil y que íbamos
utilizar en el último vídeo nos dimos
cuenta que el espacio nulo de la matriz
a era exactamente igual al espacio nulo
de la forma escalonada de la matriz andy
y si estoy diciendo que estos dos
espacios son iguales y mi espacio en uno
de mi matriz es el vector cero por lo
tanto el espacio nulo de la forma
escalonada de la matriz a pues también
tiene que ser el vector cero no queda de
otra y esto ha dicho de otra manera
quiere decir que no tenemos variables
dependientes es decir que si nosotros
nos fijamos en la forma escalonada de la
matriz a multiplicada por el vector xy
bueno pues esto sabemos que es igual al
vector 0 entonces la forma escalonada de
la matriz a se va a ver de la siguiente
manera si el vector x es el vector 0
entonces y aquí hay algo muy importante
la única manera de obtener esto es que
la forma escalonada de la matriz a sea
de la siguiente forma sea de la forma y
aquí la voy a poner y aquí tenemos el
vector x que es el vector que vamos a
multiplicar cuyas componentes es x 1 x 2
así hasta x n entonces la forma
escalonada
matriz am si tiene que ver de la
siguiente manera para que no nos queden
variables dependientes una de la otra
que tiene que ver de la manera 1000
déjame ponerlo aquí tiene que ser uno y
después puro ceros todo todo está lleno
de ceros esto en la primera fila
mientras que la segunda fila lo que va a
tener que quedar es cero después uno y
después puro ceros y en la tercera fila
va a quedar 0 0 después un 1 y después
lleno de ceros y ya te estás dando
cuenta del patrón y bueno esto tiene que
ser igual al vector 0 porque estamos
hablando de nuestra ecuación homogénea y
más aún si esto pasa entonces la forma
escalonada de la matriz tiene que ser
una matriz cuadrada de n por n y conoce
todo esto pues porque entonces mis
ecuaciones asociadas tienen que quedar
de la siguiente manera fíjate bien
tendremos que tener x 1 igual a 0
después aquí abajo x 2 igual a cero
después x 3 igual a 0 y así hasta llegar
a x n igual a 0 y en todos los demás 0
es decir esto me quedaría como a como x
10 veces x2 no hay que perder la pista
aquí sería x 10 veces x 20 veces x 3 a 7
etcétera y entonces esto quiere decir
que la matriz aumentada asociada a este
sistema de ecuaciones es la siguiente
1000 aquí puros unos y después puro
ceros y entonces aumentada con puros
ceros con el vector cero y entonces todo
esto pasa si partimos de una
independencia lineales y los vectores
columna de mi matriz caso linealmente
independientes entonces se cumple que mi
única solución es el vector x igual a
cero y por lo tanto mi espacio nulo de
la matriz a es igual del vector cero y
esto pasa si entonces la forma
escalonada de un matriz a es una matriz
cuadrada de n por eneko puros unos en su
diagonal dentro de más 0 y entonces todo
esto que acabamos de ver y es más déjame
hacerte un resumen para que no nos
perdamos de todo lo que acabamos de ver
porque fue bastante importante entonces
aquí está mi resumen de este vídeo si yo
tengo que mi espacio nulo de la matriz a
es únicamente el vector 0 entonces estoy
hablando de una independencia lineal en
los vectores columnas
esto quiere decir que los vectores
columna de matriz amp son linealmente
independientes y es un ciclo 'cine si
estos son realmente independientes
entonces ese espacio nulo es el vector
cero y bueno no solamente vimos eso lo
que vimos es que si mi única solución es
que mi vector x el vector cero entonces
cada uno de esos componentes de mi
victoria x tiene que ser igual a 0 x 1 x
2 todas éstas tienen que ser 0 es mi
única solución mi única solución y bueno
esto pasaba si entonces la matriz que
era la forma escalonada de la matriz a
la forma escalonada de la matriz am es
una matriz cuadrada de n por n que por
cierto también la matriz a entonces
tiene que ser una matriz de n por n esto
es muy importante y lo voy a ver
próximamente en alguno de mis vídeos
también la matriz con la que empezamos
es decir una matriz a tiene como
dimensión n por n pero bueno la matriz
escalonada también tiene como forma una
matriz de n por n le voy a poner aquí la
forma escalonada de la matriz a tiene
que ser de n por n
en su diagonal tiene puros hunos y en
todo lo demás tiene puros ceros y si
esto pasa entonces implica que los
vectores columna de la matriz hacen
linealmente independientes y entonces
llegamos a un triángulo vicioso y bueno
también si pensamos en un sentido
contrario es decir que si el espacio
nulo de nuestra matriz tiene otros
vectores entonces mis vectores columnas
son linealmente dependientes y entonces
la forma escalonada de la matriz
no es una matriz diagonal con la
diagonal llena de unos es decir que no
tenemos variables libres y todo está
relacionado así que nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo